Cowabunga reject Nation we got ourselves a
new trailer for Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
Mutant Mayhem joined with John Humphreys John
herriam I'm great sir Cowabunga pizza slices
all that good stuff how are you doing good
thanks for asking if you guys haven't seen
it yet uh John and Coy they have reacted
to Batman vs Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
right here on this channel it was just last
week talk about perfect metadata timing you
guys should go ahead and check that out
and while you're at it why don't you go
head over skateboard over to that like button
all right guys let's see what this trailer is
all about there's a lot of hype surrounding
this film The Turtles deserve a good movie
ah
how sweet
permanent teenager
beautiful arts talk about
spider-verse influence here yeah
into the sewer verse
let's try that again but with ninja stars
why they're really teenagers exactly like
my head just stop talking you're ruining my
concentration you're fine chill he's gonna die
did you hear that what was that well not
that we can do you guys want to grab pizza
yeah it's A Tribe Called Quest splitter
yeah love that life what was that people
what happened is Donnie bleeding
so you were baby turtles who made contact
with mystery goo well we prefer the term
ooze but yeah it's like more like it's
just it's rolls off the tongue better yeah
look at that cast Hells yeah man I stacked what
a cast well after the Kids Choice Awards of this
wide array of talents and many characters who
most wouldn't know of I expected this trailer to
really show off this massive range of characters
but instead we got one that was a pure teaser
trailer it let us get introduced to the different
animation style it's mood in the first half kind
of surprised me because it had this almost it was
a sort of Indie dramedy Vibe where you get a real
emphasis on them feeling like real teenagers their
camaraderie they're innocent yet mischievous ways
it feels like we'd be getting this let's say a
coming-of-age story as it's heart and soul yet
with this pretty badass comic book spider-verse
animation style influence the fact that they got
you know actual kids to be playing the Turtles
versus getting you know famous ass celebrities
like a Chris Pratt or some [__] like that to be
playing the turtles they they really got kids and
you you get the strong sense of that of the the
youthful quality of them weirdly as much as you
know the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles are called
the teenage muted Ninja Turtles you don't really
get the vibe of the teenager side too much
other than you know the fun side of them you
know going around the city eating the pizza
and all that [__] that they do this really
felt like ah they're the actual kids growing up
this feels like a coming-of-age story that it's
gonna be animation style that is teased here
in the trailer that lends itself quite nicely
to the turtles uh especially with the martial
arts sequences that you'll be getting here but
John what'd you think yeah I would agree I think
that's actually a really smart pull that I that
sort of Indie like like one of those movies about
a bunch of kids who are like have them have each
other they have their camaraderie but they're kind
of on their own in the world and they're sort of
wayward and left to find their own way and stuff
like that and so yeah like you said I really like
that they honed in on just the chemistry between
these four because it's the Kids Choice Awards
too they had the four of them help introduce
the thing with Seth Rogen I feel like that's
probably a very important aspect of something
like this is to get a voice cast who can really
bring that jovial sense that they really are you
know characters with this level of history and so
yeah keeping it to them you get like a brief brief
brief flash of Bebop and Rocksteady in there and
then you get April O'Neil at the very end and Ayo
had a Beery I'm just really excited for because
she's terrific on the bear and you know just so
to see her come into this as you know a voice
actor as one of the more prominent voice actors
to be featured in this particular trailer anyway
um I I think is cool and I think it's neat that
because this is Nick jumping back in you know
they've they've guided TMNT for a little while now
but I think this may be their first theatrical uh
CG animated release and so you know with that they
are kind of going back to the origin or they're
redefining the origin for this new chapter
in their uh you know shepherding of these
characters and whatnot what was the TMNT movie
oh goodness another anime that was an animated
theatrical release I saw it in theaters okay then
maybe I'm wrong it's uh because yeah because I've
seen that and I know that they were behind that
as well um but yeah I don't know maybe it's a new
kind of approach but either way I realize they
also liked yeah you said spider-verse and even
more so it felt like it had a kind of I don't know
warm hand-drawn feel uh uh you know the TMNT comic
books even have sort of an off the cuff style to
the art it feels like it was kind of like stolen
out of somebody or uh it feels like it was kind of
you know like uh ripped out of somebody's notebook
or something like that they were doodling into
and so I like that it's like very kinetic like
a spider verse but it also feels a lot more sort
of nicked and you know unpristine in a way that
is you know lived in not that is you know lazy or
anything like that I like their little joke that
they had about Shrek clearly poking fun at the
live action uh Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles film
from the Michael Bay yeah inside of things that
those uh which I didn't hate those movies by any
stretch actually but this feels more like Ninja
Turtles I heard of course that Jackie Chan's
going to be voicing Splinter Jackie Chan one of
my heroes growing up I think is a perfect addition
to be playing the mentor to the turtles here and
he's done a lot of great Voice work before they
do I just realized right now because Seth Rogen
produces and since Seth Rogen also on Kung Fu
Panda yes as well so you got Seth Rogen and Jackie
Chan reuniting together and Seth Rogen is playing
another warthog yeah yeah he's beef up and who's
who's John Cena's Rock Steady yeah okay uh but is
there like the only two extended characters unless
those three Punk dudes are gonna be mutated into
like a Mondo gecko or something like that because
sometimes I know those characters are like spliced
out of humans so maybe they will change later I
mean yeah you might be right about that they they
have the character Cynthia utram in it I don't I
don't know who Cynthia utram is but I'm aware that
that is the character uh the uteroms and it's
the race from uh prank right yeah at the race
of Krang and Krang they their race had the whole
thing that developed the mutagen that created the
turtles I'd imagine that that is a likelihood of
what they could do I'm looking at the IMDb cast
right now and one thing too that I really liked
as well is you know especially with capturing
Raphael I'm so used to them really wanting to
hone in on Raphael's uh you know edginess the
the rough side of the tracks version of him that's
something especially in the nowadays where we like
to go with the darker approach with things and
it's Raphael he's always the darker character
of them all and here they really let them just
be fun in the trailer too which I thought was
kind of refreshing especially too because TMNT he
is doing like a full Batman yeah well speaking of
Batman they're gonna have Wingnut being here yeah
voiced by a lady which I'm sure people are gonna
love I don't care sure people are not gonna have
an opinion about that but I'm excited for Roseburg
there's like a billion Ninja Turtles properties
and adaptations and it'll be fine there's there's
something about this where the animation style
has me especially excited for the action but
yeah this feels incredibly expressive it is very
spider-verse influence though it's like spider
verse but like with just a Wilder freehand almost
like it almost has a vaguely it's like scribbles
in your notebook meets an impressionist painting
them oh yeah uh which is which is beautiful in
its own way it's like beautiful but also pop art
you know which I think is very fitting of this and
and yeah if you're gonna borrow from spider-verse
which is like the new thing to do even put some
boots borrowing from spider-verse like I think
this is a nice way to at least push that style
even further down at least the drawn Direction
well yeah it has that street art Vibe yeah which
I'm which I really do like so yeah I'm sure I
won't be watching it going smarter versus my arms
crossed something like that and also if you're
going to take influence from animated property
spider versus the great things yeah sure and I
mean there have been so many iterations of the
Ninja Turtles that that Vibe I think would hold
it like if they wanted to do a Multiverse Turtles
movie that would be absolutely within the realm
yeah like might as well alrighty guys well thank
you so much for being here uh be sure to leave
a like subscribe and hey let's end this with a
and Drew Hayes you're the turtlest turtle of
them all here at the patreon my dude I feel like
you would be the perfect fifth ninja turtle you
got like the perfect halfway point between like
a Michelangelo because you got a good party
Vibe but you're also a little bit of a done
hello you know Tech you know how to pick
locks and things like that but you got that
dark side too you got that Raphael brooding in
you but I feel like you also got the leadership
uh streaking you as well Lil Leonardo little
uh Stern but also quality also compassionate
I think you would be uh the perfect yeah just
sort of auxiliary fifth member Wild Card Turtle
character that's the mutant I want for you so
a slip and fall and some oohs man get yourself
all mutated out and uh yeah then go start
fighting some crime man survive the crime
apocalypse that's what I want for you all
right yeah I like the sound of that thanks
for being here forever Andrew you'll never
leave and I love that about you thank you